hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar revealing innovations and
product launches
2021 i'm susie valdez of lab roots and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroot and brought to you
by broker photonics to learn more visit
them at brooker.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
may have during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you ever having trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker dr
marcus carter zewa a senior vice
president at r d regulatory scientific
affairs at brooker zoltonics
microbiology and diagnostics dr crosh
koster
welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
thanks for the kind introduction susie
and hello everybody ladies and gentlemen
today i would like to give you an
overview about some
innovations that we have in the pipeline
that are launching this year
in the area of microbiology diagnostics
my presentation
will contain three main topics
the first one dedicated to microbial
identification using multiply typer
where we have a system of the markets in
tears that is permanently improved and
where we i say aiming for perfection
the second part will be out about
multibiotyper
based efforts to go to susceptibility or
resistance testing while the last part
will be for infrared biotyper using for
strain typing and detailed analysis of
microbial species
so let's start
with microbial identification
the key of any system for identification
of microbes is the database that is used
for comparison and our database is very
big and is extended permanently this
year again we have an extension of our
ibtc labeled and io libraries more than
one thousand new reference entries are
added quite substantial with different
contributions from clinical species to
environmental food related species very
broad we also increase the coverage of
some species for more detailed analysis
and also to taxonomic nucleature which
is also necessary permanently
because taxonomy is permanently changing
you see here the numbers and i think
it's quite impressive we crossed now the
10 000 database entries
and
looking at the database entry content
you can also see that we reached now for
the ibdc elaborate libraries all
together the number of four thousand
species covered and i think this is
impressive this is very extensive and of
high quality
looking at the database entries it's now
even
crossing the ten thousand and 3813
are just in the main database that we
deliver to the ivt systems
but
it's just numbers now what does it mean
we just recently did a retrospective
analysis of data from 2009 so the first
year
where already the ibtce labeled system
has been used in europe
so we got from one test site
samples from their validation
and we collected from another test site
more than seventeen thousand spectra
from a year
where they used the modiby type and the
first version
and
then we analyze this spectra in parallel
to the primary version number one
version of the ibd database of multiply
tapper and with the actual one with the
ivd-11 version
and you don't have to read all the small
numbers
but
i think it's clear looking at the main
topics here
overall we see a clear improvement a key
improvement in identification result
overall and i want to point especially
here on the yeast
and on the anaerobes
which have been significantly improved
and for the data sets that we received
from these two partners from 2009 to
that day we kind of identify all of the
spectra
overall clear improvement
of the identification result but also a
higher proportion for each of the groups
of high confidence of what you call
green results
so it's not just getting more it's
getting really better
we also have this year an extension of
our already very big microbacteria
database the ibdce labeled as well as
the io labeled one
you might remember there are only about
200 species at all described currently
for microbacteria with a new extension
we cover now 182 different of this
species
we crossed the 1000th entry the mark
already put
1969 entries in this new version of the
database and there are also very rare
species contained in the database
and we will not stop but at one point i
guess we will have everything that is
described and that grows also in culture
we did not improve only the database for
microbature identification but we also
worked on the workflow on the sample
preparation
we this year introduced a new kit
that is created for the more facile and
faster simple preparation of the samples
of mycobacteria as microbacteria have a
rigid cell wall and are more difficult
to prepare
standard procedures are using
tools to open the cells and to suspend
the material
in our current method until this kit now
comes out
we are using a heat inactivation to be
sure that
tuberculosis microbacteria are
inactivated followed by a process which
uses microbeads for the suspension and
opening of cells with this kids we shift
to a chemical inactivation of
mycobacteria followed by suspension and
opening of cells using preconfigured
tubes containing small metal cylinders
those using the ayurveda but we know
those they are also used here for the
suspension of cells so this is very
simple to use it's faster than the old
process
but
the quality
is absolutely equal
so it's known that the modified tapa is
excellent in microbacteria
identification and that keeps
the same quality
on the other hand
our testers for that
gave very good comments you see here
testers from a lab where the head of the
lab told us overall the ladies continue
to be very fond of the new method
and later on he said overall the
feedback i can give is that the mtas
that's the german abbreviation for
technicians are clearly
leaning towards the new method and would
prefer to abolish the old method so i
think a clear statement for this new
method and for the kit
further we also work now on the research
use only up to no researchers on the
library for filamentous fungi for
identification with multibiotyper
we again also here extended the database
especially for some
genera like shonia richard vitron
telemysis mukhor radhisporium and
schedulesporium and overall increase the
coverage
it contains now 247 species in 73's
genera
and that's also now a view over time
where you can see that like with the
other databases we have a permanent
improvement
increase broadening of groups but also
adding of new groups in this library and
that's something we will continue and
then we will move also to diagnostic
validation
we not only worked on the database here
again we looked at the module at the
acquisition and the data interpretation
i'm looking at a lot of old data new
data
and improving
again the data acquisition in the
filamentous fungi module we have now a
new version
that is more sensitive for the
acquisition of spectra and also we saw
that we can adopt
the quality criteria
for the acceptance of high and low
confidence results
and you see here the improvement over
time
from version 1 to version 2.
overall we got a much better coverage
with high confidence identification with
the new module and the new database
which again shows how we optimize our
system over time
now
on the other hand the database is
nothing without the software
and we are in the process of introducing
now more the biotype compass ht ibd the
iv dce labeled version of the compass
high throughput software
and i will show you that this is the
ideal partner of the rapid systems
especially the modified hopper series
the software currently contains four
modules the standard identification
against the standard library
the sepsi typo module subtyping module
with the recording functionalities the
micro bacteria rbd module
so why ht software looking at the
amputee series
this is probably the fastest system on
the market for that
as for more the biotapa more diff based
identification
so typically for a very nice sample
preparation we see that two to three
seconds are enough
for spectra acquisition and in a routine
scenario it might be five six seven
seconds so if not everything is prepared
perfectly so really rapid system clearly
less than 10 minutes for us whole sample
times
now we need also with increasing
database content
we also need a software that can cope
with this and that is now more the
biotyper compass htrvd
new software
[Music]
does a parallel processing a rapid
parallel processing on several cores of
a multi-core system and by that with a
standard computer that is delivered with
a multiply typer
it's about one second for a processing
for one spectrum
in addition
it's not only faster but also
multi-instruments several instruments
can be analyzed in parallel without loss
of time
with one software with one database
server with one database that has to be
kept up to date only
so we see that three to five instruments
simultaneously can be used using just
one server without losing time
and for even more instruments and there
are indeed some customers asking for
that
higher processing speed is possible
in this case a bigger server is needed
so more calculation power at the end
so what's possible is you have a very
rapid identification consecutively on
one machine if you have one system but
also in a two or three or four or more
instrument scenario on one server
parallel identifications can be
performed or even parallel different
workflows can be performed and analyzed
on this one server
so i think this is currently also not
compared to any other system and that's
something we will expand in future with
more workflows higher speed and more
content
there's some views on the software
surface you see here that it's a clear
and simple view easy to use
you can select the batches of your bts
the standard and the matrix that you use
and register this samples can be
directly entered or imported
so very clear and easy
and
the sample type also can be selected and
can be mixed on one target so you might
have a sepsi typer samples plus standard
micro identification splice micro
bacteria
you just select the right method for the
right sample here
and then here this is the monitoring
during the data acquisition and analysis
you get a color
display about the progress and the
results you also can have a
view very intuitive on the instrument
status
the result is given not only by color
the success but also by
signature for color blind people that's
not so few people that cannot
differentiate between red and green
as far as i know so i have some
relatives known
there are standard symbols we have
introduced
and the results later on are also
clearly and simply
displayed you see the identification
with the score also subtyping and
command information and also the data at
the spectra can be inspected
like given here
just click on the symbol and you get the
spectrum and can have a look
if the spectrum was okay from quality
and everything makes sense
and at last of course there's auto
reporting reporting of over results of
single results
and
not only this also the lis or lims
export is possible as with the old
system
in the standard session
a further new function is that we've
introduced some statistics which can be
very interesting to monitor about the
progress
in the laboratory how over time the
system and also the operators are
behaving
you can run statistics for
definable time periods as an example per
month you can do identification
statistics for species you can filter
them search them search them sort them
um and you have advanced statistics as
an example how many measurements how
many runs were performed in this month
and also about species that are
discovered
you see an example uh the ranking of
species detected so e-coli is the most
prominent of course and so on we see
also distribution between high and low
confidence results
looking into a particular species here
you see the ranking of the results also
from scores
and also you can look into a species and
see for a month as an example how many
high and low confidence results were
obtained and other information
so i guess quite some useful information
for the control of the quality over time
that can be done by the user
so far about the microbial
identification with multibyte hyper
the second part now i would like to talk
about
efforts we have for susceptibility
testing and antibiotic resistance
testing with the modified topic two
examples
the first one comes from collaboration
with
clinical microbiologists
originally from university hospital
munster today university hospital of
christchurch in germany
they uh
presented at the achmed and got an award
for that so afghanistan on the phone on
the left side garden award
for his contributions to accelerate
microbiology and microbiological
diagnostics
and one component of this was the
development of an assay that uses maldi
for the rapid ast
of microorganisms
you see here the scheme the idea is to
transfer suspensions of microbes onto a
target a sample target of a moldy plate
and let the bacteria grow in the
presence of antibiotics
on the target for some hours when
bacteria grow which means they are
resistant against this concentration of
antibiotic
they will adhere to the sample target to
the multi target
because they tend to build a biofilm
bacteria don't like to swim they build a
biofilm and then you can remove
the supernatant that was done originally
manually with such a filter
can dry down add matrix and measure if
there the spectrum is generated the
spectrum is generated bacteria have
grown that means they were resistant
so that's the concept we now in
collaboration with our partners
developed a tool set for that and we
developed a scheme for antibiotic
resistance or susceptibility testing
called admob type of fast forward there
is a fast
same day process
which as described lets a bacteria grow
on multi target plates
same day after six hours of growth an
analysis of multibite up is performed to
see a breakpoint analysis for the most
urgent antibiotics
in parallel another portion of the
bacteria is grown in classical proof
microdilution and gives more information
and an mic
at the next day
this can be done from colonies but also
directly from palette that you can
obtain by the multibiotype perceptive
hyper
sample process procedure
here just a quick view on the tools we
developed a information chamber where
the incubation of the small droplets for
the growth of bacteria is performed this
has to be very nicely controlled on one
hand and also on the other hand very
dense because you don't want to lose a
big portion of your liquid and if you
think about six micro micron droplets of
course there
should be a very dense chamber that does
not lose
gas phase uh water
and
on the other hand we developed a removal
stem for the simple and standardized
removal of the supernatant after the
biofilm has spilled during the growth
with a consumable pet that is easily
removed after the stamping procedure
[Music]
so further consumables are a dedicated
plate for the antibiotics
a matrix with the internal standard for
the molding measurement
the pads that remove or are used for
removing
the supernatant of the growth
and a special broth for the growth that
is multiple compatible
again we have a dedicated software
module for the compass hd researchers
only system currently
that guides the whole workflow
automates measurement but also the
result classification the analysis
classification does plausibility checks
and warnings creates a pdf report and
also allows of course the export
this is now researchers only and we are
rolling this out in a controlled program
for studies to find out about the
routine applicability and later on we
will go to ivd studies
a side effect of this development was
that we had to validate the drying
process
of the samples
in this incubation chamber in the open
incubation chamber
and what we found here is we can
accelerate this process and not only for
the fast forward process but also for
the standard identification
so we found because the sample bit is
heated to a ancient temperature
the drying process is accelerated
and that saves time
so this was expected and we had to
validate that you see here the results
at the end we need about half the time
or even less compared to standard
drawing process on the bench in the
laboratory what was not so much expected
and positively surprising was that the
results are even getting better
so we have seen that all identification
results were not only equal but even
better than the sample process drying
procedure that is used in standard
especially that was shown also again for
yeast
so increasing not only the speed of
identification but using that tool it's
also possible to increase the
identification of success and quality
now coming to a very different kind of
antibiotic resistance testing that's
also based on collaboration
also based on a meeting at the end at
the achmed in this case it was in 2017
where the group you see here
from imperial college in london
got in the press release of the acme
because of their achievements for lipid
analysis for microbes in this case to
detect coliseum resistance of
gram-negative bacteria
so we started the collaboration with
dr la romeo and dr dorte and the
professor felu
to
transfer again the scientific results
into a tool set for later
routine analysis and in future also
hopefully diagnostics
in the process of doing that we
generated quite some publications we
tested a lot of different species and
could prove that the method can be used
broadly for different kinds of
gram-negative bacteria so there's a good
scientific basis now for that
began the task of broker was to transfer
that in a ready-to-use system containing
a process a workflow consumables and the
software data analysis
at the end for this
now all the bi-type are serious it's
ideal because the measurements are done
in negative ion mode and multiply hyper
series has the negative eye mode
inbuilt negative iron mode means
negatively charged ions are measured
not the positive ones like in the
standard procedure of multiple
analysis for proteins
we developed now for this a sample
preparation fit that enables a very fast
and simple sample preparation about 15
minutes of hands-on time no
centrifugation is just drying down in
the tube
and also a software for the data
interpretation in first case
for e coli and we will extend that in
future
so we have also first feedback from a
testing site that's from carl schroeder
in sweden
uh after testing about 90 samples e coli
with the system
feedback was that it's really above the
expectations it's easy
good results
they can easily interpret the spectre
also even without the software that's
not coming and very positive feedback up
to now especially for the handling and
for the results
so here just a quick view on the
software
again it's a multibuy type of compass hd
not ivd in this case but researchers
only version with more modules included
there is now a new module for lipid art
the lipid analysis
available
again
as you see
simple standard way to perform an
analysis you see the acquisition
progress the run progress you see also
if
the
target was
ready for measurement you can stop the
acquisition of course manually but
normally just start and the analysis
progresses
automatically also the data
interpretation analysis is done
it's giving results resistant or not
resistant the resistance is depending on
the modification of lipid a and with
lipid a is modified the mass is changed
and a new peak is generated which is
detected
it's not only can detect if it's
modified and thereby resistant but also
if it's a plasmid modification
plasmid-based modification or if it's a
chromosomal
coded modification
you also can see the spectra
for this analysis
and there is a special lobster which
gives an output if it's resistant
or not resistant
or even not to be determined
we have tested the system now before
getting on the market in a research
study
with
quite a number of 78 e coli strains
44 of them coliseum susceptible and 34
resistant all tested by micro
dilution
and those sides are very encouraging
we got overall in six-fold measurements
so that we had a
high number of spectra as you see 468
spectra of these 78 strains
and we achieved
clearly more than 90 agreement with
microdilution
and even we see now where we can do some
minor improvements to increase this
agreement so very encouraging results
something to move forward
so further development will be of course
the first to extend this to other
species other species that show this
lipid a modification
an example here is
acnetobacter he has a publication from
american group that shows the different
kind of modifications that can be seen
in acuteobacter for colistine resistance
and here using the kit the spectrum so
that will be easy to interpret in one of
the next species to be incorporated in
the software the kits not changed only
the content of the
software module the method that is
applied to this dedicated species
but the lipid analysis might also be
interesting for other purposes as an
example differentiation of species that
are difficult to differentiate using a
protein-based multibiotype or
multi-approach at all maybe also for
some other things like subtyping or
virulence other resistance has to
explore so it's a new field that is
opened and we work on this in different
collaborative studies i've given you
just a few of the partners that we have
and i think that would be an exciting
new field that in future hopefully will
guide us to more diagnostics using
multibiotyper
at last some wrote about strain typing
using infrared spectroscopy using the ir
bi typer a system based on infrared
spectroscopy that is complementing very
nicely the multibyte hyper for species
and subspecies identification
the ir bite upper given here was
introduced mainly for hygiene control
for the strain comparison of minecraft
of bacteria
and in the last versions of the verb
three we expanded that scope clearly
we opened the
wavelength
range that we use for analysis for the
full spectrum enabling more applications
we increase the connectivity to the
multiply multibiotyper so that these two
machines and kind of analysis can talk
to together and can complement each
other
we improved also visualization and
especially we introduced some
artificial intelligence some supervised
classification using artificial networks
now this year we decided to have a 3.1
improved version
that contains of course all the new
features of the 3.0 version but also is
improved in performance and display
got some maturation some better
usability but also we extended
the applications that we are delivering
ready to use to test for people
among this is that
we can differentiate the o groups from
listeria monocytogenes so our
ready-to-use
model is included in the neural network
streptococcus pneumoniae serotyping that
was delivered from the beginning was
somewhat improved by a second level
analysis for the zero group six which
has several subgroups that can be now in
the second step analyzed and determined
cerebrum 1 of liquid nanothermophila can
be differentiated from the other zero
groups
and salmonella has a zero group
classifier as the first version
and again this is not the end there is
especially in the application of
artificial intelligence classification
a lot to do and a lot to find a lot to
develop
so we have several projects already i'm
ongoing with different
collaboration partners
like differentiation of some food
relevant salmonella
salmonella differentiation of tufi and
para tufi
from other salmonella
further differentiation in the normal
coxae and looking at further subgroups
and also looking if we can differentiate
more than currently in the ligonella
area
and also for listeria
so
we're always happy for collaborators as
that this is new field and there is a
lot to contribute and collaborators with
good strains with their own ideas are
always welcomed by the bruca r d
just an example like that
at last year at the german microbiology
meeting the djhm so the last one that i
could visit live
after my talk i presented some results
about infrared wild hyper somebody came
to me
and asked me did you also
analyze salmonella para tv
and i just could answer
no
up to no not because we don't have
examples from these
so
he proposed why shouldn't we should we
work together
and
that was a good idea we worked together
together with the band at north
institute and found out that we could
build very nice classifiers not only for
summoner tv to differentiate it from
other of their zero group but also for
two of the three power two fee
and one power activity group so further
has to be investigated this already has
led to a publication
and
will be
further
analyzed of course in future in other
studies
here an example listeria monocytogenes
and as i told you
we can differentiate the zero groups
looking deeper into that we found
you cannot only differentiate the zero
groups but there are also ways with good
strains that are nicely determined
correctly determined to go deeper
if you do a linear discriminant analysis
like shown here
for zero group one two as an example
it's clear that the different zero types
in this group
are also clustering differently so a
good basis if we have the right material
to do a deeper
stereotyping
and the same here shown for the zero
group four again you see in this one
cluster using dedicated bioinformatics
further analysis further classification
is possible
and at last also there was an asm poster
this year
from customers who showed that not only
cell group one and ligonela promoting
can be differentiated from the others
but that there is also the possibility
of a deeper view in the others and
differentiate more of these zero groups
so
it's just a
in progress development we see here and
the application area
of
infrared biotyper
will complement very nicely
the multibite upper maybe even in some
areas where the species identification
and differentiation on protein bases
again is not the best
so far i hope this was interesting for
you and i could show you how we
dynamically develop and further develop
and progress with the multibiotyper and
the infrared biotyper
we will continue by that and i hope that
next year
i will be able to report about more
progress and that it will be interesting
for you again so i thank you a lot for
your attention and i especially thank
all my cooperation partners
that are working with us that help us a
lot in our development and hopefully
with good research for all of us and i
also have to thank deeply my r d staff
from software development application
development hardware development that
enable all these developments and
research which i can show you now with
this i close and i'm happy to have any
questions thank you
and thank you dr katrizawa for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q and a portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
so let's get started
we have some great questions coming in
our first question
can the ir bio typer also be used for
species identification
yeah
interesting question
actually the beginnings of infrared
spectroscopy for microbiology
aimed to differentiate spacey species
and this worked even until
a certain extent
um
the inventors at that time
had quite some success but
standardization was much more urgent
than for more debates approaches
what we see today is that it's overall
not as good as the multi-bile type
identification but in some special cases
it might be possible and we have some
indication that the differentiation is
possible where the proteins do not give
us the right answer so yes indeed it
might be complementary in future that's
something we work on
thank you so much and i see a related
question
asking will the ir bio typer look at
differentiation of kiabsciela
species
and rolotella species in the future
indeed that goes in this direction
we will see as that this is something to
investigate and i have to point on that
the same question
has to be
asked and answered for the lipid
analysis we have now two more tools that
can be investigated for differentiations
where the protein-based mode is targets
wonderful thank you so much and will the
sub typing software module be extended
also for the diagnostic applications
yeah indeed the subtyping module is a
really powerful tool and we are working
on extending that and like always we
start on the researchers only front
get experience optimize and then
transfer what is validated or what can
be validated to the ibd versions at
first the ibtce version
it will be extended we have already
planned and there are a number of
different kind of applications that we
think about one is again subtyping
subdifferentiation but it might be even
the differentiation of very closely
related species where we use again a
two-step approach in the first step the
very robust
and
very very stable identification of a
species group of two or three species
that are hardly to differentiate and
then using a detailed analysis using
modern artificial intelligence or other
tools to do differentiation
so
on the other hand virulence resistance
factors and so on all this is open and
we will work on that um i'm sure we will
extend that and whatever is
of a value we will also transfer to the
ivd system and validate that
thank you so much now dr koster zawa
how was it confirmed that the new ivd ht
software leads to identical results as
compass ivd software
yeah
very important question of course for
especially for an ipd system but
generally for a routine system
if we introduce
something new on the software side we
have to guarantee and to prove
that the results are absolutely
identical
that of course nothing inferior will
come out with new system for this we
used uh tens of thousands of spectra
that we have in our repository and
analyzed them in parallel
with both systems the old compact system
the compass ht and you have seen already
the results uh overhaul with the 70 000
spectra but that's just a subset so
using that comparing all the results of
course not visually but by the means
also again of bioinformatics we could
guarantee that we have
the same results with both systems
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
coming in
when will the database extensions end
this is a question
i ask myself from time to time
when i think 10 years
back
there was an accmet where this question
was asked to one of our customers who
gave a talk about modify typer i think
it was in vienna also and at that time
he said he thinks it's necessary to have
about 10 000 database entries
now we cross the 10 000 and it's not
over i can tell you we have already
been planning a several hundred strain
or reference entry database update for
next year so that's ongoing
it will not end it will got of course
somewhat less over time
but as taxonomy is probably changing new
species are discovered and
also we have to permanently improve our
system and check it so i don't think
there will ever be an end
what i can foresee is at one time there
will be some flattening by what we are
adding but not current we have to say a
lot of work to do and a lot of chances
to improve
thank you so much now for the ast the
result will be interpreted as
s i r
yes
yeah the fast so the rapid workflow
using more d will give only a breakpoint
analysis as ir where applicable where
the i is existing in newcast um while
the overnight workflow is micro dilution
workflow with more with more dilutions
and there are minimal individual
concentration will be given
thank you so much now doctor katjazowa
for the fast forward workflow is it
upgradeable for existing users with mvt
compass ruo or not ht
no this is a module that is only
included in ht and to be honest i can
only recommend each user to upgrade
to more db by tapper compass ht
so you don't lose anything
but you win a lot
it's a really improved system and that's
also the system where we will add
further modules in future
thank you so much and we have time for a
few more questions again thank you so
much for your questions coming in to the
audience
dr crossfield said well for the lipid
art may i confirm that this can only be
done in mbt
serious um
model
yeah yeah i can confirm that because
only the amputee series
has the negative iron mode
so you will switch the pot polarity
just to explain for the non mass spec
people
the proteins are measured in the
positive eye mode that means
ions that are positively charged are
accelerated flies with the tube and
measured now if we change the polarity
in the ion source negative ions are
accelerated and measured and for this
you need of course a special
configuration a special
hv system
and that's only incorporated in the
modified type of series
thank you very much
now could you elaborate a little more on
the 35 c drawing for the targets
yeah
okay
there's not so much detail at the end
some operation preparation is done on
the targets while they are on
this
drying chamber
incubation and drying chamber
and
as it is warmed the drying is just
accelerated also formic acid that can be
added there and also the hcca
and as said by that we observe which is
not surprising
by the
higher temperature the evaporation is
accelerated
and
we save about half of the time for
sample preparation
it this is especially also advantageous
if you have a not so stable laboratory
environment
now we know that there are customers who
have not an air conditioned laboratory
maybe in a sometimes very humid
environment
and here this controlled
temperature
controlled heating helps to standardize
even in bad situations like these very
humid summers that are sometimes
existing
and obviously also this kind of drying
improves the crystallization and the
opening of cells and by that improves
the scores
i just won here just say oh then i put
my target on a heated sample plate
it also can go in the other direction if
it's not controlled if it's getting too
warm
uh it might be
that the results like are getting less
so we have
validated this system and we control
that it is really using the right
temperature not overshooting and not
having a negative effect
thank you so much we have time for one
more question our audience member asks
pvl and staff aureus toxin confirmation
would be useful is that being looked at
absolutely correct it would be
interesting
we up to now did not look at that they
are on the standard
procedure within protein measurement
there were already analysis with some
success that was not confirmed so it's
not really possible as we know today
but again that's something where we
should use our new
application our new tools that we have
and have a look again two new chances
with infrared spectroscopy and lipid
analysis
dr costrazewa thank you very much for
your time today and for your
presentation would you like to provide
any closing remarks for our audience
before we go
i think you might be on mute
did i lose you
doctor crossroads
well i think we lost him but i want to
you again dr castro zawa for your time
and for your important research
and i want to also take the time to
thank lab roots and our sponsor brooker
daltonix for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time
take care everyone
and bye